make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
okay so we are covering spider-man but
here's something that i want to throw
out there real quick right because i
know some people are going to ask the
question
rob didn't you cover this already what i
covered was spider-man 2.
uh here's the important thing about this
right spider-man is probably one of the
most important spider-man stories
i'd say of the last 15 years and the
reason why
is because this is the story where peter
parker
first met miles morales right so um one
of the things we've talked about here
over the course of really some of the
miles morales videos that we've done and
a lot of the peter parker videos that we
did is we kind of talked about the
nature of the ultimate universe right so
if you guys are familiar with this we
just finished the video yesterday where
we talked about that the miles morales
one right so just kind of bear with me
right we'll probably have some new
people to the channel
i know you guys kind of like to get
directly into it but bear with me for a
second while i kind of
kind of reiterate this uh for for the
people who are new here right who are
new to marvel comics um in marvel you
have a great big huge multiverse right
technically the marvel cinematic
universe
is considered part of the multiverse
that makes up all of marvel comics
uh we know that for a couple different
reasons one because it actually has a
numerical designation
among the marvel multiverse and two
because there's comics based on it right
so that kind of brings it closer in line
with being part of the marvel multiverse
but
where you had marvel comics as it was
originally launched in the 1960s right
with the fantastic four number one and
so on and so forth
that's referred to as earth 616 right
also known as
the main marvel universe what we got in
in the year 2000
was the creation of the ultimate
universe and this was an answer to the
question what would it look like if at
that point in time in the year 2000
superheroes had just basically popped up
right they just kind of emerged for the
very first time uh what would the what
would those superheroes look like how
would they function how would all that
stuff work uh and that's basically where
you got peter parker in the ultimate
universe now
ultimate spider-man was exceedingly
popular right it was hugely popular
because in a lot of ways it was kind of
an indirect reboot right marvel didn't
really
reboot everything with the main marvel
universe spider-man they just gave us a
new one and people loved it right people
absolutely loved it but what you saw was
a story where basically peter parker
died right peter parker spider-man was
killed and it might behoove us to go
back and cover that event right cover
cataclysm and the death of of peter
parker right it might behoove us to do
that just because you know we're kind of
doing a lot of this stuff because the
new spider-man game is coming out for
the playstation uh but the idea is that
when that version of peter parker died
uh we ended up getting miles morales in
his place and when miles morales first
showed up there was a lot of naysayers
there were a lot of people who were just
kind of like miles morales sucks he's
not really spider-man he's not really
peter parker that kind of a thing
because it kind of came from a couple
different places a lot of fans were
latched on to the idea of peter parker
even when they were reading him before
the ultimate universe was launched right
so all they really got was just another
alternate reality version of peter and
they loved it a lot of people grew
attached to peter parker spider-man in
the ultimate universe when that was
their first place to start
in marvel comics but by whatever manner
and whatever means a lot of people just
didn't want to see things change
this story is in a lot of ways kind of
brian michael bendis
snubbing people who were naysayers of
miles morales right uh people who were
just like this this character's not
gonna last or anything like that it was
kind of been just being like
no he will like he's gonna be around for
a long time and that's really where this
comes from and i tell you that because
it's important that you understand the
historical context of this story
as we get into it so you can understand
why this story is considered to be so
important with all that out of the way
let us jump to the main story itself uh
and so what we end up getting here is
picking up in the main marvel universe
or 616 with peter parker spider-man and
is peter parker just kind of doing the
stuff that peter parker does right like
swinging around coming across some
criminals some guys who are doing some
things they're not supposed to do but
here's the funny thing about this
because of the fact that this story was
written as a way to kind of tie into or
kind of bring together the ultimate
universe and the main marvel universe
this story was written in such a way to
where it was designed to treat people
as if they're aware of who spider-man is
but they don't really know much about
him right they don't really know a whole
lot about the character right so it's
kind of reiterating the nature of peter
parker and that's one of the things that
you see
in marvel comics there are certain
characters out there who people know who
they are right people know who iron man
is now people know who spider-man is
people know who wolverine is
but knowing of knowing who the character
is and understanding the history and the
context of the character are two
distinctly different things
you know so a lot of people know who
iron man is but i doubt they really know
anything about the mandarin or i doubt
they know about stories like demon in a
bottle and why it's so important uh what
is it the five nightmares run by matt
fraction
different things like that right arnold
stark kieran gillen's run a lot of
people probably aren't really familiar
with that so uh the idea is that we're
just kind of giving peter parker in
terms of how peter parker operates but
just to say kind of amusing to himself
about how much he loves new york city
and the fact that new york city is kind
of like a thinking breathing entity
right that there are so many facets to
this city you've got people who have
their nose to the ground and they're
just grinding day in and day out just
trying to make it by
you've got people who are just super
high up in their ivory ivory towers you
know the tony starks the reed richards
who don't really have to worry about
small time things right but you kind of
have everybody who falls in between and
there's just
so many different varying types of
people in the city of new york that is
just
so unique in that way what it also has
are criminals
there's criminals in new york city and
spider-man goes to visit some
and he basically wallops him one or two
times shows him what for
and then of course you know ends up
pulling over the vehicle which is their
getaway car and as soon as he's there
he's met by the arrival of the cops
right and the cops are just like take
off your mask show us your face you know
that kind of a thing now the truth about
this is i was never really part and
parcel to this kind of depiction of
spider-man of peter parker and the
reason why is because you have had
stories over the years
where jay jonah jameson and the daily
bugle have kind of managed to sort of
turn
you know the the idea of spider-man into
something where he can't really be
trusted he's a menace but the the long
and short of it is that over the years
spider-man was
largely trusted by society right you
know your friendly neighborhood
spider-man he was the good guy right he
was largely trusted in that way there
have been times where it's waxed and
waned but in this instance
i kind of feel like it should have been
one of those things where it's like
thanks spider-man you know and that's
that's kind of it right now the fact
that the cops show up here and he's
behind the
behind the wheel of a getaway car might
give him a little reason to be suss
right but i don't know why i say that
all the time mariah started saying suss
and now i say it all the time right like
suss it's a weird word but anyway uh
once he takes off and he kind of you
know goes and does this thing he ends up
finding this building you know
this kind of uh this office building
basically where the the
the roof has been shattered right the
glass has been shattered and he's kind
of like that's a little weird now of
course he ends up being drawn to that
location because of a giant bright light
almost kind of an explosion of sorts and
of course once he gets there like the
whole place
kind of seems to be tarnished right and
there's just this white light or this
bright light emanating from it all now
as he gets in there and as he starts
investigating his initial thought is
this energy source is a little weird now
this story was released about a year
after spider-man big time and for those
of you guys who aren't really familiar
if you ever wanted to get into
spider-man i always suggest people start
with big time we have that that whole
series covered on my channel and big
time was the start of dan's slots
run you had spider-man and you had mary
jane who were like married and all that
kind of stuff and then you got one more
day then you got brand new day where
marvel basically nullified it all uh
because that was just so poorly received
big time was kind of marvel's huge shift
with peter parker right focusing on like
an all-new age for peter parker
spider-man uh but that's kind of a good
place to start right because dan slott's
run
begins with that and runs all the way up
through secret wars and after secret
wars into clone conspiracy right so it's
a it's like a 10 almost 15 year long run
of spider-man it's very very lengthy but
i think it's also
incredibly good i think it's an amazing
run on spider-man but the whole idea
behind this
is that uh that this takes place about a
year after that now the reason why i
mention that is because i'm not entirely
partial or partial to how this is
handled by bendis right vendis is
notorious
for writing a character and then
pretending like nothing anybody did ever
happened right and it's just like the
only things that matter with this
character is what i'm doing here
and ignoring continuity in its entirety
now whether it's kind of venus is always
that way i'm not 100 sure i wasn't
really reading bendis back when he was
part of uh of event publications with
jimmy palmiotti and joe casada i wasn't
really reading him back then
i only really got familiar with brian
michael bendis once he actually came in
the main marvel itself and was writing
like new avengers right uh and new
avengers was a wholly new thing so he
could kind of get away with that uh
it's something that i think maybe a
result of his like his huge amount of
popularity and it's kind of like i'm
bendis i can do whatever in the heck i
want i don't know if that's really the
case or not but the reason why that
matters is because during spider-man big
time peter parker's intelligence had
always kind of been downplayed by marvel
comics right they never really
kind of elevated peter parker to being
on par with like reed richards or tony
stark you always kind of knew he was but
they never really did any of that for
him
instead what you end up getting here is
peter parker kind of looking at this and
just being like man this is weird he's
like it's not it's not you know anything
alien in nature uh maybe i should get a
hold of like tony stark or reed richards
or something like that during big time
one of the big things that dan slott did
was focus on the intelligence of peter
parker and in being like peter parker's
actually pretty daggone smart and he
doesn't always need reed richards or
tony stark to solve a problem on his own
that was kind of solidified in a story
where there was like a bomb that was
going to go off and nobody else could
defuse it and peter parker was the one
who did
right so it was kind of elevating his
intelligence up and basically telling
the reader base hey peter parker's not
as dumb as he's being made out to be you
know he's not just a spider-man right
he's a super intelligent guy
let's start treating him that way so i'm
not entirely partial on how this works
but as he starts navigating this room he
starts to realize all this stuff belongs
to mysterio right all these things
belong to him and that's when mysterio
tries to sneak up behind peter and
attack him and of course peter parker's
spider sense goes off and he basically
ends up you know kind of kind of being
aware that he's about to be attacked and
manages to dodge out of the way now with
mysterio and one thing that a lot of you
guys are probably aware of after having
seen spider-man far from home
mysterio is a legitimate credible threat
to peter parker right he's probably one
of peter parker's most dangerous
villains his ability to cast delusions
to basically trick peter parker and his
spider-sense it can be pretty difficult
to overcome mysterio and that's one of
the reasons why you have you know peter
parker kind of saying here like i've got
to get this guy down as fast as i can
because this guy is a real
and serious threat the other part of
this is that mysterio keeps rambling on
about how like peter parker's ruining
things
and he's kind of destroying things and
and so on and so forth and then he goes
as far as to say
like you have no idea what you're
dealing with right you have no idea what
i'm capable of uh i missed out when you
died the first time
i'm not going to miss out this time
right so right off the bat our cue is
that this is some kind of ability for
from mysterio to actually look through
into the ultimate universe where that
version of peter parker died and
mysterio
wants to be in that universe where peter
parker doesn't exist right his main
nemesis the person that always foiled
his plans he's just trying to find a way
to escape and so what you end up getting
here is is peter just kind of looking at
this and saying like like what is this
thing right is this some kind of a power
generator or whatever this is it's weird
that this is here but like i can call
people they can basically break this
down
and take this thing apart so we don't
really have to worry about it right
while peter parker
doesn't really know what's going on with
this device he knows enough about
mysterio to know it's probably not a
good thing right like when super
villains start doing weird things
you don't understand you can usually
just assume it's bad and you're not
usually wrong in doing that
it's a good rule of thumb to have but of
course in his desperation mysterio
ends up grabbing uh grabbing a handgun
and firing it off and then missing peter
parker and hitting his device
and when that happens he's yanked
through right peter is seemingly yanked
through
into basically the ultimate universe and
this is the first time
one of the reasons why this is so big
this is the very very first time in the
history of marvel comics that a
character from the main marvel universe
crossed over into the ultimate universe
right this was a huge deal now the
ultimate universe
it exists now in marvel comics but it's
nowhere near as a big deal as it was
back in like the early to mid 2000s
right at around the time and even really
in the early 2010s when this story was
written uh this is when the ultimate
universe was really kind of at its prime
depending on
you know what you were reading there was
a lot of falloff after the death of
peter parker you know
we can't really you know that's just an
absolute thing we can't really argue
that point but the death of peter parker
in the ultimate universe actually made
headlines right it made national news
headlines and so because that there was
a lot of interest in the ultimate
universe and so it was really a great
time to capitalize on that right to kind
of give us this story but this is a big
deal
when this first happened and so as peter
parker's there he's like okay
this is weird like it's suddenly daytime
uh i don't know what that great big huge
building is over there that's the
triskelion that great big huge
tower looking thing off in the water uh
you guys probably recognize the
triskelion from
uh captain america the winter soldier
that's where this comes from that's why
we say the marvel cinematic universe is
a combination of the ultimate universe
uh the main marvel universe in earth 98
where the heroes age in real time uh
it's kind of a combination of those
three things but he ends up traveling
back to the building
where uh where you had you know the
whole um you know mysterio's base of
operations and everything popping off
and uh and he basically ends up breaking
into the place only to find out that
it's occupied with some girl in a towel
and he's like
my bad it basically bails out right ends
up taking off
from there he actually ends up rescuing
a guy who's you know kind of being uh
being beat up a little bit he takes out
the two of the two people who are
beating this dude up and he basically
says he was just playing pool and then
suddenly they jumped him
but the fact that he's wearing a peter
parser a peter parker costume wearing a
spider-man costume
does not go unnoticed by this guy and
he's like look i appreciate you saving
me but like it's really in bad taste for
you to wear that costume right now
what's more so than that he's like you
know we all need heroes but that was
peter parker's costume and that's one of
the big things to know when peter parker
died and and even peter parker was
spider-man his identity was known right
when when all that popped off
his identity was known to the world
people were like the world needs to know
that this is the kid who who tried to
save everybody who died a hero that's
why the death of peter parker was so
massive in the ultimate universe right
like imagine for example that like in
the main marvel universe in marvel
comics that iron man dies and it's this
great big
huge event that crosses over every
single
comic that they have right it's like the
death of iron man you know the
incredible hulk tie-in and the captain
america tie-in and all that kind of
stuff right like everything ties into
just the fact that iron man died and how
everybody's coping with it that's what
the death of peter parker was
it was just huge it was massive because
spider-man had never actually been
killed off in marvel comics with no
intention of bringing him back right
that's just never happened before right
i mean what will kind of tried it with
the clone saga but like that was never
gonna happen uh with the ultimate
universe it's the way it is peter
parker's been dead
you know like the the peter parker
spider-man concept is dead and miles
morales has taken it over and it's been
that way ever since so
it was kind of a big deal it was a huge
deal when it happened but this guy that
the fact that this guy reveals that they
know who peter parker is
really throws like the main marvel
universe peter parker off because his
identity is something that he keeps
insanely close
guarded right now in the in in civil war
he revealed it to the world just as kind
of a proof of the fact that he trusted
iron man superhero registration but of
course as we saw in the aftermath of
that brand new day that doctor strange
came along and just
magicked everybody's memory of peter
parker's identity out of their heads
right he's just like you
magic and then nobody remembered that
peter parker was spider-man and that was
essentially it right that was basically
it that's probably what they're going to
end up doing in spider-man 3 the movie
but the the whole point behind
this is that this throws peter parker
for a loop because he's kind of like
okay
that's crazy like wherever it is they're
referring to me in the third person
so one this guy doesn't know who i am
but he knows who peter parker is
so that means there was a peter parker
here in this place what in the world is
going on right now and so what ends up
happening is he's ultimately met by the
arrival
of miles morales and miles morales pops
up and he's just like
no way right because to the eyes of
miles morales this is the ultimate
universe version of peter parker it's
like peter parker has come back that's
what kind of blew things off right
that's what drive
that's what makes miles morales kind of
go nuts here but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob corp if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you